Netflix's the spy is a six-part
miniseries recounting the life and death
of Elie Cohen an Israeli secret agent
who was instrumental in providing Israel
with top secret information within the
highest ranks of the Syrian regime well
Sasha Baron Cohen no relation takes on a
rare dramatic role who are the real-life
characters portrayed in the series are
some of them even real and what did the
show leave out in this video we'll be
taking a look into the real-life spies
and characters from the spy spoiler
alert if you haven't seen the show the
driving force of the spy begins with
then Prime Minister of Israel David
ben-gurion chewing out Mossad member
jakub Shah Moni due to their lack of an
Inside Man in Syria an event which
pressures shimonita direct Mossad agent
handler Dan Peleg to recruit someone and
fast both Jakob Simoni and Dan Peleg are
not based off real characters rather
they're derived from a collection of
characters to make the story easier to
follow it is possible however that both
Dan and Jakob characters could be based
heavily off mere a meet who was then
director general of Mossad and was the
one responsible for coming across Elie
Cohen's name in the pile of rejected
candidates a scene which is portrayed by
Dan's character in the show Dan who acts
as Ellie's handler over the course of
the series expresses his concerns over
training someone in the short time frame
that the Prime Minister has requested
who have six months not today more
impossible it's also interesting that an
actor who spent six years portraying a
man weeding out spies on the Americans
is now playing a character who actively
helps them
Dan's hesitancy to take on someone so
quickly is spurred by what happened to
one of his former agents a man who's
only known by his last name
Burak this is also a fictitious
character used as a plot device to
motivate Dan's unwillingness to hire
Ellie who will get to in a bit Dan knows
the price that comes when an eager agent
willing to prove himself is put into the
field too early he's got something to
prove he wants it too badly I understand
you feel responsible for him don't
patronize
dan feels responsible not only for the
deaths of his former agents but for the
families they leave behind this is why
he feels obligated to help Ellie's wife
and children by buying them supplies
cooking them breakfast and checking up
on them from time to time Nadya Cohen
Ellie's wife is in fact a real person
they married in 1959 and as the series
portrays she did not know about her
husband's involvement in Israeli
intelligence in the last episode we see
Ellie writing his final letter to her in
which he says the following I am begging
you my dear Nadia not to spend your time
and weeping about something already past
concentrate on yourself looking forward
for a better future remarry so that the
kids have a father and you have a
partner Nadia
never remarried she also had a third
child with Ellie a boy who is never
depicted in the show
Nadia would spend the rest of her life
commemorating Ellie and along with
Ellie's brother Maurice tried to get his
remains sent back to Israel Maurice
Cohen is another real character and as
depicted in the show attended to the
incoming telegrams for the Mossad and
like in the show discovered his
brother's secret identity while
decrypting incoming messages from agent
88 Ellie's codename Ellie Cohen was a
risky choice for the Israelis born in
Alexandria Egypt Ellie had a criminal
record for alleged scientist activities
following a military coup in 1951 when
the Egyptian government stepped up
Jewish persecution he moved to Israel in
1956 where he became a
counterintelligence analyst it was when
he was rejected by Mossad that he
resigned from the military and worked as
a filing clerk although Ellie was a
risky choice he was also perfect because
of his Arab background not only did he
speak Arabic he looked Arab - something
that never made him really fit in in
Israel you know what they see when they
look good I know what I see
that's it she was yes with the help of
Mossad Ellie was trained physically
mentally and was taught how to speak
with a Damascus accent it was then that
he was given that alias camel a mean
Hobbit a wealthy businessman who would
later infiltrate
Argentina it was in Argentina that Ellie
began hosting lavish parties and
befriended then Syrian military attache
I mean al-hafiz a relationship he would
cultivate that would eventually lead him
to become the Syrian Minister of Defense
in the show Ellie's depicted as
showering ameen with expensive gifts to
gain his trust a technique he utilizes
to gain access to other influential
people such as Sheikh Majeed al are now
I couldn't find a photo emoji but I did
stumble across an interesting story not
covered in the show when Israel found
out Ellie's connection to him they knew
he had connections with Nazi war
criminal Franz Rademacher who had fled
to Damascus and changed his last name to
Rosello Ellie use moji to locate
Rademacher and provide a description to
Israeli intelligence after his move to
Syria Ellie would befriend a soldier
named Zahir mazi who was nephew to the
chief of staff of the Syrian army abdel
karim jihad in the same military officer
who le would help overthrow so that
Hafiz could take power in the 1963 coup
d'etat mazi would prove instrumental in
providing Ellie with pivotal information
showing him important positions of
military personnel and bases where
future fortifications were to be built
Ellie recounts that one time when mozzie
was staying over at his place he noticed
an unusual radio antenna and asked Ellie
what it was for Ellie explained it was
to pick up radio signals coming from
Buenos Aires which mozzie never even
questioned Ellie's relationship with
Hafeez however would put him under the
looking glass of ahmed suis donny
who was appointed as syrian intelligence
colonel he was a man that trusted no one
in disliked cohen immensely so much so
that on Ellie's final trip to Israel he
asked that his assignment be terminated
but with the idea of having a spy in the
second-in-command position in Syria too
much to give up Ellie was sent back to
Syria where he would later be found
unbeknownst to Ellie Swede Annie had
stepped up efforts to find the mole
within their ranks and hired Soviet
experts with tracking equipment to
locate any illegal transmissions Ellie
was indeed caught in the act of sending
transmissions to Israel upon his capture
but perhaps the most infamous cameo in
the series are the bin Laden's
both Muhammad bin Laden and his son
mastermind of 9/11 Osama bin Laden who
is seen briefly here as a child
bin Laden Eden Elian is shipping hookups
to discreetly ship large pipes to be
used in an operation called shell out
whereby the Syrians would drain Lake
Tiberias cutting off Israel's access to
fresh water in my research I couldn't
find any mention of Chillon or Eli
Cohen's connection with bin Laden so the
extent to which this was dramatized in
the show has me questioning its veracity
but if you happen to know more I'd love
for you to comment below that's it for
this video I hope you learned a little
bit more about the characters in the
show and I want to hear your thoughts in
the comments and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe with that Belon for more
videos you can follow me on twitter at
think story whitey and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much